en este vídeo hablaremos de las
propiedades básicas de los exponentes
generalmente los exponentes son números
enteros positivos pero también pueden
ser números negativos o incluso pueden
ser fracciones o números decimales
pueden ser muchas cosas pero empecemos
con el caso más sencillo miren un
exponente es una forma abreviada de
escribir algo por ejemplo supongamos que
tenemos 3 por 3 por 3 por 3 por 3 como
pueden ver tenemos 5 3 y cada vez que
multiplicamos algo por sí mismo en lugar
de escribirlo todas las veces
simplemente podemos escribirlo de una
forma más compacta al escribir 3 elevado
a la quinta potencia esto nos dice que
tenemos al número 3 multiplicado 5 veces
por el mismo y esto nos da una de
nuestras primeras reglas básicas que
dice que si tenemos un número a elevado
a la potencia m y lo multiplicamos por a
elevado a la potencia n lo que
necesitamos
es simplificar eso sumando los
exponentes por ejemplo si queremos
simplificar 3 a la cuarta por 3 al
cuadrado
simplemente sumamos los exponentes y nos
queda 3 a la sexta y si lo pensamos un
poco tiene sentido porque 3 a la cuarta
es 3 por 3 por 3 por 3 son 4 y 3 al
cuadrado es 3 por 3
entonces si contamos todos los tres que
estamos multiplicando podemos ver que
tenemos 6 y eso es lo que nos dice esta
regla ok ahora la siguiente regla básica
dice que si tenemos un número elevado a
la potencia m dividido entre ese mismo
número pero elevado a la potencia n esto
lo podemos simplificar al restar los
exponentes al exponente de arriba le
vamos a restar el que tengamos abajo por
ejemplo si tenemos 3 a la cuarta entre 3
al cuadrado esto significa que tenemos
tres por tres por tres por tres
tres por tres así que podemos cancelar
dos de esos y nos queda tres al cuadrado
arriba que es lo mismo a que si
hubiéramos restado los exponentes cuatro
menos dos bueno veamos más propiedades
de los exponentes y después veamos
algunos ejemplos más complicados la
siguiente propiedad dice que si tenemos
a elevada a la potencia m
y todo eso elevado a la potencia n esta
vez hay que multiplicar los dos
exponentes por ejemplo si tenemos 2 al
cubo y todo eso elevado al cuadrado
bueno recuerden que cuando tenemos algo
elevado al cuadrado significa que ese
algo se multiplica dos veces y 2 al cubo
es simplemente una forma abreviada de
escribir 2 por 2 por 2 y como tenemos
otro 2 por 2 por 2
al final cuantos 2 estamos multiplicando
claro 6 y obtendríamos lo mismo al
simplemente multiplicar los exponentes
desde el principio también obtenemos 2 a
la sexta
entonces esta es otra propiedad básica y
una variación de esto es cuando por
ejemplo digamos que tenemos a x b
elevados a la potencia m
en este caso como tenemos dos cosas
adentro del paréntesis que se están
multiplicando podemos tomar una elevarla
a esa potencia y multiplicarla por la
otra también elevada a la misma potencia
esta es otra regla básica de los
exponentes y para convencerlos de que
esto es válido supongamos que tenemos 2x
y todo esto al cubo esto es igual a 2x
por 2x por 2x entonces multiplicamos 2 x
3 veces porque están elevados al cubo y
podemos reordenar los ya que todo se
está multiplicando así que vamos a
reordenar lo como dos por 2 por 2 por x
por x por equis y así nos queda 2 al
cubo porque tenemos 3 veces el número 2
por x al cubo porque también se
multiplica 3 veces entonces esta es otra
regla básica que deben de saber y bueno
en realidad no lo he mencionado pero con
estas reglas no importa si están usando
exponentes positivos o negativos sin
importar el exponente esto será
verdadero y bueno en el último caso que
es una variación del anterior supongamos
que tenemos a entre b a la potencia m en
este caso nos queda a elevada a la m
entre b también a la m y nuevamente
espero poder convencerlos de esto con un
ejemplo supongamos que esta vez tenemos
dos entre equis y todo esto elevado al
cubo bueno esto significa que tenemos
dos entre x por 2 entre x por dos entre
x así que tenemos 2 por 2 por 2 y eso es
igual a 2 al cubo y x por x por x es
igual a x al cubo obviamente podríamos
simplificarlo desde el principio pero
pero vamos a dejarlo así ahora hagamos
un par de ejemplos un poco más
complicados combinando todas las reglas
supongamos que tenemos dos a la cuarta
elevado al cubo bueno esta es la
propiedad de los paréntesis así que
simplemente multiplicamos los exponentes
y nos queda 2 a la 12 que sería lo mismo
que si multiplicamos el número 2 12
veces ok ahora supongamos que tenemos 2x
y todo eso elevado al cubo bueno
nuevamente podemos elevar todo a esa
potencia así que nos queda 2 al cubo por
x al cubo y en este caso voy a
simplificarlo un poco más porque sabemos
que 2 al cubo es 2 x 2 por 2 y eso es
igual a 8 así que nos queda 8 x kubica
porque x al cubo no se puede simplificar
más ok continuemos supongamos que
tenemos x a la cuarta y todo eso elevado
al cubo entre x cuadrado bueno debemos
de tener cuidado no podemos simplemente
cancelar las cosas inmediatamente porque
en este caso lo que tenemos en el
denominador no está elevado al cubo
solamente x a la cuarta pero si
simplificamos el numerador usando la
propiedad de la multiplicación de
exponentes 4 por 3 es igual a 12 y eso
entre x al cuadrado si hacemos esto
ahora simplemente podemos restar los
exponentes recuerden el de arriba menos
el de abajo así nos queda como 12 menos
2 y eso es igual a x a la décima
potencia hagamos otro supongamos que
tenemos que a la quinta al cubo por ye
al cubo al cuadrado y vamos a dividir lo
entregue a la cuarta elevada a la cuarta
bueno primero vamos a simplificar lo que
tenemos en el numerador si multiplicamos
estos dos exponentes nos queda que
15 por llega a la sexta y todo eso entre
si usamos la propiedad de la
multiplicación 4x4 es 16 y ahora vamos a
simplificar el numerador que nos queda
como ya la 21 entre ya la 16 y ahora
podemos usar otra propiedad en la que
esto es igual a la 21 menos 16 y así nos
queda ya a la quinta esa es nuestra
solución hagamos uno más
supongamos que tenemos x cuadrada porque
al cubo entre x a la cuarta y todo eso
elevado a la quinta bueno lo primero que
haré es que como todo esto está elevado
a la quinta potencia primero necesitamos
simplificar lo que tenemos adentro del
paréntesis así que tenemos que al cubo
arriba y si escribimos x como x por x
entre x por x x x por x
miren abajo tenemos 4x y podemos
cancelar todos con las 12
de arriba entonces nos queda que kubica
entre x cuadrado porque solo nos
quedaron 2 y todo eso elevado a la
quinta potencia y nuevamente si usamos
la propiedad de multiplicación de los
exponentes 3 por 5 nos da que a la 15 y
2 por 5 nos da x a la 10 esta es nuestra
respuesta final entonces estas son
algunas propiedades básicas de los
exponentes y recuerden que pueden usar
exponentes fraccionarios o negativos o
lo que quieran y no hay problema